let's say we have a 0.20 molar aqueous
solution of acetic acid and our goal is
to calculate the ph and the percent
ionization the ka value for acetic acid
is equal to 1.8 times 10 to the negative
fifth at 25 degrees celsius
first we need to write out the balanced
equation showing the ionization of
acetic acid so acetic acid reacts with
water to form the hydronium ion h3o plus
and acetate which is the conjugate base
to acetic acid because acetic acid is a
weak acid it only partially ionizes
therefore we need to set up an ice table
so we can figure out the equilibrium
concentration of hydronium ion which
will allow us to calculate the ph and
the percent ionization in an ice table
the i stands for initial concentration c
is for change in concentration and e is
equilibrium concentration
the initial concentration of acetic acid
is 0.20 molar so we can put that in our
ice table under acetic acid and if we
assume that the reaction hasn't happened
yet the initial concentrations of
hydronium ion and acetate anion would
both be zero
some of the acetic acid will ionize but
since we don't know how much we're going
to call that x so we write minus x under
acetic acid for the change part of our
ice table and when acetic acid reacts
with water we form hydronium and acetate
so we're going to gain in the amount of
our products to figure out how much we
look at mole ratios from the balanced
equation there's a one to one mole ratio
of acetic acid to hydronium ion
therefore if we write minus x for acetic
acid we're going to write plus x under
hydronium and for the acetate anion
there's also a one as a coefficient in
the balanced equation therefore we can
write plus x under acetate as well so
the equilibrium concentration of acetic
acid would be 0.20 minus x let's go
ahead and write that in here 0.20 minus
x the equilibrium concentration of
hydronium would be 0 plus x which is
just x and for acetate it would also be
0 plus x so we can just write x here
next we brought out the equilibrium
constant expression which we can get
from the balanced equation so the ka is
equal to the concentration of the
hydronium ion and since there's a
coefficient of one that's the
concentration of hydronium ion raised to
the first power times the concentration
of the acetate anion also raised to the
first power divided by the concentration
of acetic acid raised to the first power
and water is left out of our equilibrium
constant expression because the
concentrations in our equilibrium
constant expression are equilibrium
concentrations we can plug in what we
have from our ice table so we can plug
in x for the equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ion x is also the
equilibrium concentration of the acetate
anion and .20 minus x is the equilibrium
concentration of acetic acid we also
need to plug in the ka value for acetic
acid at 25 degrees celsius
here we have our equilibrium
concentrations plugged in and also the
ka value our goal is to solve for x
which would give us the equilibrium
concentration of hydronium ions however
if we solve for x here we would need to
use a quadratic equation
so to make the math a little bit easier
we're going to use an approximation
we're going to say that
.20 minus x
is approximately equal to 0.20
the reason why we can make this
approximation is because acetic acid is
a weak acid which we know from its ka
value ka is less than one and that means
it's only going to partially ionize it's
going to ionize to a very small extent
which means that x must be a very small
number and if x is a really small number
compared to 0.20 0.20 minus x is
approximately just equal to 0.20
so we can go ahead and rewrite this so
we would have 1.8 times 10 to the
negative fifth is equal to x squared
over and instead of 0.20 minus x we're
just going to write 0.20
solving for x we would find that x is
equal to 1.9
times 10 to the negative third and
remember this is equal to the
equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions so let's write in here
the equilibrium concentration of
hydronium ions so this is 1.9 times 10
to the negative third molar if we would
have used the quadratic equation to
solve for x we would have also gotten
1.9 times 10 to the negative third to
two significant figures therefore using
the approximation got us the same answer
and saved us some time
also now that we have a value for x we
can go back to our approximation and see
that x is very small compared to 0.20 so
.20 minus x is approximately equal to
0.20
also this concentration of hydronium ion
is only from the ionization of acetic
acid and it's true that there's some
contribution of hydronium ion from the
autoionization of water however that
concentration is much smaller than this
so for this problem we can ignore the
contribution of hydronium ions from the
autoionization of water
next we can find the ph of our solution
at 25 degrees celsius so ph is equal to
the negative log of the concentration of
hydronium ions so that's the negative
log of 1.9
times 10 to the negative third
which is equal to 2.72
we also need to calculate the percent
ionization so the equation for percent
ionization is equal to the equilibrium
concentration of hydronium ions divided
by the initial concentration of the acid
times 100 percent the equilibrium
concentration of hydronium ions is equal
to 1.9 times 10 to the negative third
molar so we plug that in and the initial
concentration of our weak acid which was
acetic acid is 0.20 molar
so the molars cancel and we get a
percent ionization of 0.95
percent
a low value for the percent ionization
makes sense because acetic acid is a
weak acid
we can also use the percent ionization
to justify the approximation that we
made earlier using what's called the
five percent rule so let me write that
down here the five percent rule if the
percent ionization is less than five
percent as it was in our case it was
less than one percent actually then the
approximation is valid if the percent
ionization is greater than five percent
then the approximation is not valid and
you have to use the quadratic equation